und die proteste
endlich angesprochen
[Gelächter]
krankheitssymptom im sommer raum mit
brustimplantaten
kurz bmi frau richter beschwert dass
ihre silikonimplantate lokführer in der
medizin die stadt sauber hat aber
umstritten machen wir zu beantworten
existiert eure meinung nach periode
nicht
ganz konkret ja das existiert das placet
noch anders aus das ist
unser traum silikon brustimplantat
möglich lang machen
[Musik]
übernommen und wechselt andreas andrä
street riske und 19 als nachbar und
ziellos sich wenige wochen bestimmt
wieder osanna was die eigenen ressort
schlimmer ausfiel josef zemp montiert
die einfach krank
sein kann
dieses gerät offenbar eine von denen
frauen in ihrem so genannte phänomen
casting band ins leben übrigens bewusst
phänomen group rest im plus ist ein
offiziell anerkanntes krankheit aber es
geht eben mehr frauen gesundheitliche
probleme mit der zeit merkt dass ihre
implantate unter dass auch sie in
amerika geht es zum beispiel sie bei ihr
immer mehr communitys da es mit mehreren
betroffenen und auch in europa weil es
keine
[Musik]
dann drehe ich einige frauen wo man für
die reportage geschicht verzögert sich
aber die einzige verdienen wo
es langsam aber eigentlich nicht vor der
operation centers vierte august
stattfindet wie nie mittels vor steuern
ebt
mit gut mittag die frohe - könnten nach
nur 2 julie de thier unterschiedlicher
und diffuse symptom modisches meter
rücken und modisches methode jetzt im
moment
bin ich so richtig
krankheit wo tut extrem schuppig und
juckt weiteren schuppenflechte nach
stammsieben andrea ohne probleme zu
machen
ja ja wirklich unverträglichkeit
entwickelt puffer damit
testen was gut und was mit gott und
produkt gar nicht so gut
plötzlich
sprach mit der betroffene weiß was für
beschwerden wie brest implant illness r8
unspezifisch sie und
autoimmunerkrankungen
anschließend und zum teil auch erst
jahre nach der implantation
[Musik]
mit andrea sich genommen schon nach der
ersten zwei hauptprobleme auf tochter
abfangen so mit kopf- nacken- also
völlig kopf schon schwierig
[Musik]
die ganze optisch so in worte und
das ist extrem gut und du musst die
extrem
konzentriert am schluss ist ähnlich wie
fax immer gesagt
wenn sie das ganz ihrer implantate
auf einer facebook gruppe
aber so genau die es im dom
st
klein geschmerzt hat bronze kurs für
gastlichkeit bis zu black outs für ganze
gespräch und konzentrationsstörungen das
war der unterschied hätte andrea mit
denen betroffene frauen gemeinsam
swissmedic bestätigt wird jetzt mit dem
aufdruck von mir wo sie kenntnis von dem
phänomen andrea ich habe im vorfeld
nicht über 35 grad wurde
auf risiko schraubt zu viel tun muss und
schönste garten
natürlich
aber das gibt es selten
[Musik]
ihre recherche würde und seine
geschwister website für plastische und
ästhetische chirurgie
und tatsächlich hat
wenigstens zu birgit
ludwig gibt es aber auch greifen das
heißt arzt muss ohne zu sagen wie für
frauen der schweiz möglicherweise
betroffen sind konnte mir nicht sagen es
gibt noch karten für arzt für das
phänomen
[Musik]
wird sauber wisse wie es auf
kleinigkeiten
wie facebook algorithmus meine recherche
jetzt ständig vor der ganz bestimmte
klinik zeigt wie genau der
last minute angebot was heißt da die
operation hat er schon selbst sagen will
also schwer lastminute fredeburg
eigentlich
ist
eigentlich sogar krebs gesprochen
und informieren wenn ihr operiertes
lasst mir nicht beratungsgespräch wird
das image termin muss fixe für eine op
würde es denn schon fix ist
facebook noch leben sie bezug auf das
video
implantierte größten reise ist das
riesenthema der patienten grundsätzlich
hätten rechte und es gibt so vieles
gefühl hängt das sich vor dem und das
ist dann vor dem ich glaubte er lügt
will das implantat unternehmen sind
beschränkt wie hat es in stahl und wo
haben wir das mit sie im schnitt
bewiesen philipp hat deshalb den
placebo-effekt das placebo kann alles
verursachen dass ich als kuriose und
genauso ist mit dem rest implantieren es
so das heißt die frauen sich bei einem
wort aus wie ein drk-sprecher ist die
klinik zu zahlen und der gedanke hinter
mir lassen mit angebot ist nicht mehr
wegnehmen werden heute für euch das ist
nicht komisch in der placebo effekt
haben punkt auf viel klarer und es gar
nicht darum bislang nichts machen den
placebo-effekt ich weiß nicht wie es das
wissen die sind gestorben am pc perfekt
es gibt todesfall vom placebo-effekt
wirkt so extrem glaube dass sie das
mittel über vor mit denen klassische
bewirke aber
patienten sind trotzdem nicht wenn ein
grund sei dass vielleicht hat aussagen
ja das ist blödsinn das stimmt nie viel
ich bin ich total falsch finde ich
merken jahren vom us studie doch das und
das ist jetzt der grund und ich auch
sagen placeboeffekt rische dem index von
mir
denn meistens hat er einfach nicht aber
ich finde perfekten spannenden satz mehr
fracht speziell gewirkt dass man zur
last minute angebot macht ja ich glaube
sie unterschätze die das geschlecht wenn
man dem film ich dass man das thema hat
mit der festlichen schon jahrelang der
mine der frau mit sprechstunden und
einen leidensdruck die worte es schon
viele jahre und sie könnte sich
wahrscheinlich mit ihnen viele wie sie
den sack mit hand und 1 gerettet ein in
dem kurzfilm ins schwarze es ist nicht
dass irgendein überleiter gebracht
werden ich glaube das ist auch dass wenn
die user aber es ist nicht unüberlegt da
würde sie an das war unsere oder frau
gegenüber extrem
aber im endeffekt ist zu jeder frage ob
sie von bord gebracht
der doktor und egis einig die ehefrau
mit bhs im domino weiter die
sportkleidung liebe skeptisch für mehr
sind nur komisch ehrlich
wissen voraus sicher so sie wenn man die
iphone erkennt
und den katalysator
und die recht heftig strom ergebnis ist
eine halbe oder arbeits und
weitere kontakte mit telefonieren und
sechs hin und habe vor dem richter
ich glaube monat zu informieren
dort setzt man hier wirklich scheiße 27
minuten im bett liegend oder zuhören
glück nach einer der hof mache gar auf
merkel ich sage immer das ist verdächtig
schmerzt das nicht vorstellen künftig
wirklich wie vergiftet so aushalten
irgendwelche
so hat sie übrigens nova 44 wo sie noch
keine implantate bis über zwei jahre
nach dem eingriff ist gut gegangen aber
dann ist gesundheitlich rapid war gab
mit der jetzigen 25 jahre teilweise
hätten sie da nicht mit der von patti
koche geschafft und extrem abgenommen
über ein jahr lang ist im inselspital
bern vor ort zu ort geschickt wurde dem
bond auto seiner sie haben angst
mediziner tod christi maxi
gefährlich und dem kontaktmann kranke
irgendein film und augenlider und
körperbild nicht schlagen sie verdammen
und das ist psychisch und psychosomatik
15 7 mio auszählen und ja ich war da
eine be lebensstation als sehr
unterschiedliche stationen
sind so spielt obama mit aussagen
konfrontiert und sich lieber mobilitäts
drei klare bilanz und lud aktuellste
medizinische erkenntnisse zusammenhang
zwischen brustimplantat und volker frank
rieger das bedeutet sehr sorgfältig und
interdisziplinär die mögliche ursache
klar und brustschmerzen bevor er griff
vor wird noch deutlicher abklärungen
hätten sie spielt dann aber doch
operation zurück stunden einigkeit sich
aber schlussendlich im juni im
kantonsspital aarau den part von
doktorand blog law exportieren
telefon
kurz an
der implantat müsse und zwar jetzt
also eigenen das komplette zeit
knapp behauptet nach der explosion nicht
besser sagt sie sie hat zwar noch immer
schwächer aufbau und extremer müdigkeit
aber intensität vor dem dom hank
abgenommen und für sie ganz verschwunden
deswegen
habe ich vom stammkader sind einen bern
gewählt du fühlst dich so so mvc für und
das ich will keine punkte im la reunion
ist
hoffnungslos pixel kritik west haben
[Musik]
hat ihn jetzt damit alle getroffen und
mit ihrer tochter und blogs kreuznach
controller dieser person den anbau
private probleme zwischen sieht auch die
termine
ich wollte sowieso auch mit arzt
referees
[Musik]
relativ schon begegnet ihre recherchen
eigentlich mekka für ein arzt der ort
ist
und dass ich immer noch sehr umstritten
drum hat es
existiert eure meinung nach bei oder
nicht
ganz konkret ja das existiert es ist
eine erkrankung die schlecht erforscht
ist die wir bis heute nicht gut
verstehen dessen symptomen komplex den
man schlecht erklären kann wir haben
eine
reaktion des körpers auf dem
fremdmaterial
und das komische ist dass diese reaktion
im körper stattfindet überwiegend und
gar nicht unbedingt am ort also an der
wusste frau wie macht ihr aber
mittlerweile studie also multi richtig
weite sie gemacht aber noch keine studie
keine handwerker machen fest was hat das
linke dass man wird gar nicht rund und
teil der symptome reichten den
psychosomatischen
themenkomplex rein
wo ebene
körperliche symptome vorhanden sind und
die psyche in den großen einfluss hat
und dort ist es auch für uns chirurgen
immer wieder schwer greifbar dass jemand
eine erkrankung hat die nachweisbar als
als komplex ist und alles was wir so
nicht sehen können was wir nicht schwarz
auf weiß belegen können damit tun sich
viele einfach nach wie vor schwer dass
das dann auch existiert
zu dem thema darf ich noch ganz gut das
video zeige
das ist das kuriose und genauso ist mit
dem rest implantieren es also
zum teil stimmt mich natürlich über
einen
placeboeffekt
körperliche symptome hervorrufen kann
und grundsätzlich wird das hier auch
vorstellbar ich persönlich glaube nicht
dass es nur ein placebo effekt ist wir
stimmen glaube ich überein dass es eine
verbesserung gibt in einem ganz hohen
prozentsatz wenn man die implantate
entfernt und wir stimmen überein dass
die patientinnen immer recht haben das
heißt die konsequenz dort landen weil
ich beim gleichen punkt
das ist genau der punkt dass es eben
viele frauen gibt die von dem thema
vorher noch nie was gehört hatten und
vorher schon beschwerden hatten und ein
placebo wirkt ja wenn man im prinzip
eine gewisse
erwartungshaltung mitbringt und das
trifft auf diese frauen nicht zu die
haben spontan von sich aus beschwerden
beschrieben und haben dann auf der suche
im internet foren gefunden wo sie was
über die erkrankung gelesen haben im
druckzentrum vom kantonsspital aarau
wird aber nach wie vor mit silikon
implantat geschaffen neben sind ganz
anderes beispiel wirklich aus dem
konsumbereich sie kaufen den auto und
dann haben sie irgendeine form von
garantie dabei und hier haben sie
eigentlich nur eine qualitätsgarantie
dass die operation fachgerecht
durchgeführt wird sie haben keine
garantie dass sie keine komplikationen
haben dass sie nicht so eine
risikogruppe gehören und sie haben auch
keine garantie dass sie implantate
lebenslang halten übrigens ddr
blockpartei pilotstudien auf beisteuern
danke mit der pilotstudie versucht
herauszufinden ob sie so genannte markt
geht außer reaktion vom immunsystem oder
entzündungsfaktoren und künftig quasi
wir können jetzt testen die studie macht
derzeit mit dem verein risiken von
silikon brustimplantaten schweiz panik
und andrea eigener verdampfer 41 beruf
und sie von alexa und der natürlich
sofort an stellen wollte es ist ja nicht
jede frau lohfink prompt reagiert
weismachen worden dieser genetische
disposition ist wieder energie aber fakt
ist das einfach ein großer prozentsatz
für frauen mit infront ein problem hat
das ist einfach wenn man 80 prozent der
energie in pompöser nachmittags land
einfach gesundheitliche besserung
alex und natalie bei die wie hilflos
sagt 30 betroffene fühlen sie hat das
alles so sauber zurück macht und
versuche das künftig ersparen und es
dann grund engagieren sie sich
ehrenamtlich für die information und
aufklärung zu dem thema und vermitteln
auf acht personen wie der doktor blog
von ihr selber betroffen ist es extrem
verunsichert das einfach ich schwitze
ich mir gefunden hat sondern nur in
deutschland zwei gruppen
deutschsprachige sie damit um dass wir
sagen implantate sind nur schlecht ich
verstehe die frau das implantat ersetzt
aber vielleicht das nötige wissen habe
ich auf einmal problem könnte duft auch
dass man reagieren
[Musik]
schon gar nicht ins team mit die nötige
die stadt zum thema und wir überhaupt
unternehmen aber das geht man acht danke
das thema und frank hat die geschichte
über eine frau die
barriere mehr sie eigentlich dankbar
[Musik]
dass ich weiß wie sie meinte ich solle
andrea ich übrigens wird einkaufen dr
blog kooperierten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dies
ist für mich wichtig sid zum locations
gesehen jetzt nach vier jahren das ja
noch nie so lange meine andere hätte 24
oder das sortiment spect anders
noch so intakt
und wenn du die bewegte störfall und
das
war oft
so dankbar jetzt mussten sie als gäste
sind
immer
noch
mehr oder weniger geisterte wir jetzt
gesehen und so
vorstellen
ich muss jetzt wohl
heute früh haben schon ganz kurz die
fotos angeschaut
das sind die implantate mit kapseln
das so gut dann so markieren das sind
hier oben auch die fäden
implantate waren völlig intakt das ist
die mundhöhle das können dann noch
vergrössern noch zu zeigen dass man
wirklich die ganze kapseln entfernt hat
und
was darf die lippen brachte mit sich
sind nun
das ist schwierig vorherzusagen wir
wissen dass über das erste anderthalb
zwei jahre etwa 80 prozent der patienten
die symptome besserung erfahren bei
denen die
[Musik]
in dieser zeitspanne keine symptome
besserung erfahren bleibt das letztlich
offen was die ursache war teil von denen
hat dann über fünf jahre eine gewisse
verbesserung
und ein paar beim patienten bleiben die
symptome letztlich unerklärt oder man
kommt dann noch auf andere fach
diagnosen durch media für die gleichmann
wer durch jetzt schon besser ich
glaube das lässt sich jetzt noch nicht
nachweisen
die folgen von narkose von einer
operation betreffen eigentlich auch den
ganzen körper das ist ja noch mal eigene
einflussfaktor aber die positive
einstellung dass ich was verbessert das
ist glaube ich eine gute voraussetzung
für eine gute beurteilung und das ist
die zweite woche später nach der
operation schickt man d'andrea spruch
mehr ehrgeiz besser der tv angesetzt
die superflachen offenen rücken
verabschiedet johanna als auch bezüglich
die wissenschaft werde und auch kein
mediziner aber nach der app buchen mit
ganz vorstellbar dass die bahn steckt
d'andrea und da nicht aber die anderen
frauen mit einem kredit wirklich zeigt
wie er aus gesunde frau plötzlich
kranken frauen war und zum teil durch
psychopharmaka verschrieben oder
schlafmittel
strange aber brust-op sie ist richtig -
und flog im haus bzw großes bedürfnis
wirklich über die ja oft klarer und
metropolis finger was meinst du glaubst
du die betroffene frau oder das phänomen
ist nur die partie
gekommen
und wenn die themen